EU PROSECUTION:
Have you noticed that almost all big court rulings
against tech monopolies and for tech regulation
comes from the EU? Within just the last 6 years,
European countries have taken action against
Google 7 times, Apple 2 times, Facebook 3 times,
Microsoft 1 time, and Amazon 1 time. This usually
consists of billions of dollars worth of fines,
lawsuits regarding anti competitive practices,
investigations into power abuse, and of course
new standards for Apple. And those are just the
most notable cases from the EU. For perspective,
the biggest lawsuit that American authorities have
brought against big tech in recent times is suing
to block Microsoft from acquiring Activision
Blizzard. And, in the end, this didn’t really
do anything anyway given that Microsoft ended up
closing on the deal later the same year. As such,
the EU has often been described by the press
as being the last regulatory body that’s truly
fighting to keep big tech in check. But while
their efforts have painted as somewhat of a
valiant hero, this relentless pursuit has not
been without consequences. For example, Europe
has not big tech companies of their own. In fact,
the only 2 European tech companies that even make
the Fortune 100 are ASML and SAP. In contrast, 7
of the top 10 largest companies in the world are
American big tech companies. At this point, you
can even argue that Berkshire Hathaway itself is
just a tech holding company given that almost half
of their portfolio is just Apple stock. Europe
is also getting the short end of the stick when
it comes to big tech compensation with big tech
companies regularly paying Europeans 25-50% less
for the exact same jobs. Yet despite all of this,
the EU has continued their noble pursuit
of maintaining free markets and minimizing
monopoliziation. Just last month for example, the
EU started investigating Elon Musk’s X. But why?
Does the EU truly just care that much about their
people and corporate landscape? Or is there some
more ulterior motives at play? Well, here’s the
real reason why the EU keeps prosecuting big tech.
LEFT BEHIND:
Taking a more macro perspective,
it’s likely that Europe’s moves against big
tech are less of an offensive move and more of
a defensive move. You see, Europe has been getting
left behind within the tech industry since really
the 1960s and 1970s, the era in which Silicon
Valley was born. We saw the rise of gen 1 tech
companies like Fairchild Semiconductor, Intel,
AMD, IBM, Microsoft, and Apple. This was largely
thanks to the high risk high reward mindset of
Americans across the board. In terms of company
leadership, you had a bunch of 20 year olds
with no experience dropping out of college and
betting it all on a company. In terms of venture
funding, Silicon Valley almost created a sort of
self sustaining funding model. The winners of
each decade would go onto become billionaires
and establish their own VCs and incubators that
supported a whole new generation of startups. And
in terms of regulation, all of the laws were set
up to reward winners as much as possible while
also subsidizing losers as much as possible. This
meant lower taxes for companies, less regulation,
government grants, tax credits, political
favors, and so on. On the flip side, if your
venture didn’t work out, you still enjoyed solid
bankruptcy protections, the ability to try again,
and sometimes even government bailouts. This sort
of landscape was simply pushed into overdrive
when President Ronald Reagan came into power and
implemented his controversial Reaganomics. He cut
the personal income tax rate from 70% down to 28%,
the corporate tax rate from 45% down to 35%, and
he would be dubbed the Great Deregulator. Whether
these moves were actually better for America over
the long term or not are highly debated, but
one thing is for sure, these moves basically
paved the road for trillion dollar giants and mega
billionaires. At the same time, Europe was taking
a far more conservative approach. They stuck
with their high taxes, focused on social welfare,
maintained tight regulations, and they were
largely risk averse. In fact, to this day, 8 out
of the top 10 countries with the highest personal
income tax rates are European countries. 9 out of
the top 10 countries with the highest sales tax
rates are also European countries. And social
security tax can be as high as 65-68% in Europe.
What this means is that it’s not uncommon for even
middle class Europeans to pay over half of their
income to various taxes. And if you’re a wealthy
European, you could be paying as much 70-80% of
your income to various taxes. For contrast, 40%
of US households don’t pay any federal income tax
whatsoever, and the highest income earners often
get away with the lowest tax rates. Again, whether
this is healthy or not is highly contested,
but one things that’s for sure is that it’s far
better to be a rich person in America than a rich
person in Europe. And as such, taking stupid high
risks to become stupid rich is far more appealing
to Americans. In Europe, it simply makes far more
sense to reduce risk with increasing net worth as
more and more of your income will be handed over
to the government anyway. For the longest time,
this difference in mindset didn’t really incite
an economic difference. The American tech industry
was just a niche portion of the economy while the
real heavy weights were pharmaceuticals, banks,
retail giants, industrials, and energy, sectors
in which Europe had a bunch of their own heavy
weights. But, all of this changed with the turn of
the century after which tech became the dominant
player. Since then, Europe has been falling behind
across the board whether it be return on invested
capital, growth, capital investment, or R&D. And
all of these shortfalls are almost single handedly
due to just tech. In fact, McKinsey estimates
that over 90% of the shortfall in return on
invested capital, over 60% of the shortfall in
growth, over 80% of the shortfall in investment,
and over 70% of the shortfall in R&D are due
to Europe’s tech inferiority. To make things
worse, big tech and America have been
playing Europe for fools for decades.
PLAYED FOR FOOLS:
While Europe has been quite successful at taxing
their own citizens and companies, the same cannot
be said about American companies who have insanely
sophisticated ways to avoid taxes. Take Apple for
example. They like to hold the vast majority of
their intellectual property in countries with
extremely favorable tax laws like Ireland. This
way, they can minimize their international
tax load by funnelling the majority of their
profits through these tax havens. Last year for
example, Apple made just over $110 billion out of
which $70 billion went through Ireland. It’s
the same thing with Microsoft, Google, Meta,
and any other big tech company you can think
of. Schemes like these are why Amazon was able
to get €44 billion worth of sales from Europe
without paying a dime in corporate tax. Now,
to be fair, big tech companies leverage these
same strategies to avoid American taxes as well,
usually at even larger scales, but it’s a
completely different dynamic. For starters,
these companies employ millions of Americans who
earn multi six figures who end up paying a crap
ton in income tax, sales tax, property tax, social
security tax, and so on, even with America’s
more favorable tax laws. But let’s even put tax
revenue. Even if big tech companies paid identical
taxes to America and Europe, the 2 are not even
comparable. It’s almost like comparing Jeff Bezos
to the average American. Before Jeff retired,
he was only earning a modest $81,840 on paper,
an amount that’s quite comparable to the average
American. Now of course, you’re probably saying
that Jeff was earning tens of billions through
stock appreciation and you’re completely right.
So, let’s say that Jeff wasn’t allowed to sell any
of his $100 billion Amazon forune similar to how
America isn’t able cash in on the profits earned
by big tech. Jeff would still not even be close to
being comparable to the average American despite
only earning $80k. This is because Jeff would
still have leadership over a trillion dollar
company, influence over a million employees,
control over a third of the global cloud market,
and sales of over $500 billion just to name few
perks. Also, he could borrow against his
Amazon fortune to fund an insane lifestyle
without selling a cent of Amazon stock. It’s the
same case with America as a whole, just at a much
larger scale. Sure, they may not make much tax
revenue from big tech, but their still the home
country to tech companies worth tens of trillions
with dominant control over the entire globe’s tech
and internet. The raw amount of power, influence,
wealth, dominance, and control that America get’s
from big tech on a macro economic and political
scale is incomprehensible. China saw that this
is where things were heading back in the 1990s,
and that’s why they banned most American tech
giants and created their own tech giants. Europe
on the other hand largely ignored this trend and
did virtually nothing to cultivate their own tech
hub. 20 years later, this has left Europe in a
much less desirable of simply being a consumer of
tech as opposed to being an owner of tech. And if
we look back at history, the key to power and
wealth has been control over capital throughout
the entirety of human history. From the ancient
kings who owned entire regions of land to the 18th
century land owners who forged fortunes using
slave labor to the gilded age industrialists
who controlled every sector known to mankind, the
key was always capital. For the past 1000 years,
Europe has been the leader of global capital, but
over the past few decades, they have effectively
dropped the ball in regards to tech capital. And
now, they’re trying to claw back as much tech
capital as possible with the help of regulatory
control bringing us to modern day Europe.
EUROPE’S LAST STAND:
With all of this extra context,
it becomes apparant that all of the EU’s lawsuits,
regulations, and fines are less of a heroic effort
to keep big tech in check and save the world or
something and more of a last ditch effort to save
themselves in the new global order. Bill Gates
has long speculated that Europe is on it’s way to
becoming an open air museum for Americans and East
Asians. And honestly, this reality is looking more
likely by the day. They’ve been falling behind
for half century, they’ve transitioned from being
owners of capital to consumers, and now, they’re
using their last political resources to simply
delay the inevitable because let’s be honest,
that’s all that’s happening. I mean, do you
really think Apple has any less global power just
because they had to switch to USB C earlier than
they would’ve wanted to or that Google or Facebook
really care about the multi billion euro fines
that cost a few weeks worth of profit. Of course
not, this is just the cost of doing business and
maintaing international relations. Also, about
taxes, Europe has been trying to get big tech
to pay more taxes through new regulation.
And these efforts have been successful at
generating more tax revenue but there’s just
one problem. It’s not the big tech companies
that are paying these taxes, it’s Europeans as big
tech companies are happy to directly pass on the
cost to European consumers. That’s why iPhones
cost hundreds of dollars more in Europe. So,
the sad reality is that Europe’s antics against
big tech is not only not hurting or even slowing
down these giants but oftentimes, their
policies are backfiring and ending up costing
Europeans. None of this is to say that Europe
is gonna end up as the 3rd world or something,
but a fate like Japan seems increasingly likely.
A stagnant region that is cashing in on the glory
days of the past. Do you see a different outcome
for Europe? Comment that down below. Also,
if you’d like to learn more about Europe’s rapidly
crumbling tech salaries, check out this video.